hey guys it's katie and today is a brand
new day and i thought it would be really
fun if i made my own starter for
sourdough bread from scratch let's call
my friend marissa who makes bread for a
living and she's going to help us figure
this out let's do it
hey hello how are you
i'm great first question what is a
striker so a starter is just a mixture
of flour and water and it's what you're
eventually going to use to leave in your
sourdough bread i use a mix of 100 grams
of warm water 50 grams whole wheat flour
and 50 grams bread flour i'm gonna mix
it up and cover it with a lid then i put
a rubber band around the outside to mark
movement you're looking for a consistent
rise and fall of the starter let's walk
through like what that first week is
like we're gonna check in on the starter
i'm gonna take a look at it and i'm
going to see if there are any signs of
fermentation i'm looking for a sweet
funky smell see if there are any air
bubbles and if we're seeing those
bubbles we know it's time to give it a
feeding if you still don't see those
signs you can wait another day the
feeding is when we discard a lot of the
starter from the container and we feed
it fresh water and flour and that allows
the colony of yeast to grow within the
new flour and water keep doing this
process daily for about a week it's
possible that it could take a little
longer though depending on your
environment this was super helpful
marissa i'm gonna get to it get in it
awesome i'm excited and check in with me
during the week okay
i will check in with you i'm you know
i'll need to bye
okay after talking with marissa i'm
gonna start my starter first i have a
scale this is just gonna help you
measure a lot of bread recipes are in as
you can see grams or ounces a scale is
awesome to have i've got a clear
container that i'm gonna put it in tear
this so this goes to zero and then i
have some wheat flour and i have some
bread flour and some water
[Music]
i'm going to set this on my kitchen
counter because it's pretty warm in my
kitchen day one and done
see you tomorrow
it looks like it rose like up just a
tiny bit
oh
you guys can see those bubbles that are
going on there so definitely have some
life
it has a little bit of sweetness i
definitely think like marissa said we
should wait another day and check on it
and we'll see you tomorrow
see i just got out of the shower and i
saw my starter and i'm pretty excited
take a look at it
whoa
it's so alive it was pretty warm because
i shot in my kitchen yesterday so i
think that really helped look inside
delaney
whoa all the bubbles so since this is
going strong marissa said we need to
discard
almost all of it we're gonna keep two
tablespoons and i'm gonna give that a
hundred grams of water and a hundred
grams of flour
and then with the discard you don't have
to throw it away you can cap it put it
in the fridge i'm gonna use it for
pancakes tomorrow morning
bye
day three done
okay it's another morning and my starter
has risen again not quite as fluffy but
it looks like it came up you can see
that line right there and kind of shrunk
back down and there is a lot more
bubbles
oh definitely more sour smelling today
still sweet but it's got more sour in
there so i'm gonna discard all of this
except two tablespoons again i'm gonna
add 100 grams of warm water 100 grams of
flour and i'm gonna make pancakes with
this discard and my discard from
yesterday
[Music]
how do you get it more round
chris is filming my husband
hello
hey
[Music]
oh
yeah
all right chris no i'm really good yeah
what are you worried i'm eating broccoli
good for you
those are really good there might be
more of like um i've had whole wheat
pancakes they're kind of more like that
it's really good i think they're great
how's it going it's going i'm checking
in because it's day
five and i'm just not getting like a lot
of movement on
my starter and i don't know if it's
because it's so cold in my house right
now
yeah i think like you could wait for a
little bit more bubbles on the top
um those signs that we've talked about
and then feed it it it will start to
level out it's still really new and
young and like learning the process okay
great all right well i'll just keep i'll
keep going i'll keep observing it okay
good luck yay all right bye
[Music]
okay so it's day seven five and six i
just left this guy alone marissa said if
it's not really writing that much let it
sit and do its thing before you feed it
but now today
on the seventh day it has a lot more
action going on so i'm gonna discard
most of it especially because i let it
sit for two days and then i'm gonna feed
it again 100 grams of water and 100
grams of flour and then i think that
we're gonna have starter that i can make
bread with like tomorrow
hey everyone i know i said i'd be
checking in with marissa tomorrow but i
just i had to show her my starter today
because it basically doubled in size
awesome just so you know like day five
and day six like not much was happening
there wasn't many bubbles on top today i
had all these funky bubbles when i
opened it up and then i fed it i mean
that to me that sounds like you're being
intuitive like we can say feet every day
but
those first few days like if you want to
let it go a little longer to see a
little more of those signs of funkiness
before feeding sounds like you did the
right thing because look at it now right
as long as you don't see any like black
mold if it's like a sludgy brown black
layer that's called hooch and you can
like pour that out but if it's fuzzy at
all black mold blue unfortunately you
might have to start over it but this
this is looking great let's just try the
float test get a cool cup of water and a
spoon
okay on it i'll be right back
for the float test you're gonna take a
clean scoop of the starter and then
you're gonna put it into the water and
when i say clean scoop it's just what
you did we're trying not to like stir it
up because you want to see those bubbles
oh it's so floating marissa oh my gosh
oh my gosh i wish i could be closer oh
it's just kind of fun to do but i don't
waste my starters what should we name
this baby the name priscilla came into
my head
oh priscilla i love priscilla this can
definitely be priscilla do you think
she'll be ready to like mix and make a
loaf like in a couple days
yeah i think we should give it a shot
let's say after you make that bread you
know you're not gonna bake for a few
weeks what i would do next is feed your
starter
and then put it in the refrigerator you
can keep it there indefinitely
just feed it once a week do a refresh so
final question if people watching want
to make bread when should they feed
their starter if you want to mix your
bread in the morning you could feed it
right before going to bed about eight
hours if you want to make dough in the
evening you could feed in the morning
about eight hours you just need to make
sure it passes the float test marissa
this was so helpful thank you so much
i'm so proud of myself and priscilla i
hope you guys try this at home if i can
do it you definitely can do it and if
you guys have any more baking questions
hit marissa up at bakerbui on instagram
and check out our bread making video
when that comes out and make a loaf with
us
peace and loaves
peace and little peace and loves all
right uh i'll see you later
bye
oh yes
[Music]
foreign